good afternoon everyone thank you for
joining us we'll have time for a brief
statement
because this is an ongoing investigation
we won't have time for questions please
good afternoon my name is charles jones
i'm the supervisory senior resident
agent
here in wyoming for fbi denver standing
with me here today are acting chief
ranger matt wilber with the national
park service
hunter bailey who is chief of the
national park service investigative
services branch
we also have teton county sheriff matt
carr and jackson jackson police chief
michelle weber
first and foremost on behalf of the fbi
personnel
and our partners i would like to extend
sincere and heartfelt condolences to
gabby's family
joe and tara petito
and jim and nicole schmidt
as every parent can imagine
this is an incredibly difficult time for
the family
and friends
our thoughts and prayers are with them
we ask that you all respect the privacy
as they mourn the loss of their daughter
as you are aware fbi personnel in
coordination with our partners at
national park service the forest service
teton county sheriff's office and
jackson police department have been
conducting an investigative activity in
the vicinity of the spread creek
dispersed camping area
earlier today human remains were
discovered
consistent with the description of
gabrielle gabby petito
full forensic identification has not
been completed to con confirm 100
percent that we found gabby but her
family has been notified of this
discovery
the cause of death has not been
determined at this time
we appreciate your continued support and
patience as we work through this process
the vicinity around spread creek
campsite will remain closed to the
public until further notice
this is an active and ongoing
investigation so we ask everyone
maintain distance from law enforcement
personnel and equipment
vehicles and related activity for their
own safety as well as to protect the
integrity of our work
and respect privacy for gabby's family
we appreciate the tremendous support
from the public
the support from the public's response
to request of tips has been remarkable
we continue to seek information from
anyone who utilized the spread creek
dispersed camping area between the dates
of august 27th and august 30th
anyone that may have had contact with
gabby or her boyfriend or who may have
seen their vehicle in that area
please share any new information with
the fbi at tips.fbi.gov
or 1-800 call fbi
and finally the denver field office
direct is 303-629-7171
photos and videos can also be uploaded
at fbi.gov
backslash petito
we thank our partners at the national
park service the u.s forest service
teton county sheriff's office and
jackson police department for their
collaboration and diligence in this
investigation
they surged their resources
um in a very short amount of time and
their personnel have been intimate or
have intimate knowledge of the rugged
terrain that we're dealing with
which made this process much more
difficult
we greatly appreciate the invaluable
skill and expertise of the teton county
search and rescue team
we also thank the community of jackson
and the surrounding areas for the
hospitality and for accommodating a
rapid influx of personal law enforcement
personnel in the area
in order to protect our investigative
process and increase probability of
successful prosecution should it be
necessary we have no additional comments
we appreciate your cooperation and
respect for gabby's family loved ones
during this difficult time thank you